[Music]
everyone's searching for something
fulfillment
alliance wins they win
ti3
fame ppd here comes the ice blast ready
for the dog
satisfaction
gives you the ability to become someone
else
a someone who is powerful thank you man
ravaged on everyone the black hole as
well flight abandoned turns it around
ravaged as well stolen by danny why are
you kidding me they turn it around
express their creativity
[Applause]
break the rules without actually getting
arrested still hasn't even been used
there's a hook
hell
brought all the way back to the base
cleaned up by the film all of these
reasons are in there somewhere the
player himself might not even know he
might not even understand it himself
but it's there
defense of the ancients also known as
dota was first introduced as a mod for
warcraft 3 reign of chaos back in 2002
it took inspiration from a custom
starcraft map called aeon of strife a
co-op mode in which four players faced
off against an endless wave of
computer-controlled units across several
lanes
from the beginning especially offered
something that
other games didn't really have dota was
created with warcraft 3's world editor
which turned the game's existing assets
into a variety of unique heroes and
items it was the first in a long line of
multiplayer online battle arenas better
known now as mobas dota has such a
scattered scattershot history it was
originally developed by a lot of
different people and eventually a guy
named yule stepped up and took lead the
objective of the game was simple destroy
the enemy team's ancient a structure
which sat behind towers and waves of
units but the execution was a different
story
torah was always a very difficult game
and a kind of hard game to get into
especially if you're a casual gamer
players would need to choose a character
from hundreds of heroes a mass gold and
experience by killing player and
computer controlled units and outfit
them with items and unique abilities in
the hopes of achieving glory i think
that torah really
you know brought something new to the
table where it was
even harder to some extent to to
play on a team
and
make it work the advent of dota marked
the birth of an entirely new multiplayer
experience it was like an rts but better
it had the complexity of a game like
starcraft but with a welcome reduction
in actions per minute
more importantly it introduced the
element of team play to a genre that had
always been designed around individual
play
i see it in a lot of ways similar to
basketball just like a five-on-five game
where you kind of have to work together
and utilize each other's strengths and
synergizing everything together
the teamwork and the trust and the
sacrifice those are all true for every
single team sport although the first
ever iteration of dota was released by
kyle yuell sommer it wasn't until the
release of warcraft 3 frozen throne in
2003 that the genre truly began to take
off
given that yule had stopped supporting
his own mod other map makers were left
to produce spin-offs that added
additional heroes and items amongst
other features the most popular of those
spin-offs was dota all-stars given that
it took everyone's favorite additions
and compiled them into a single
downloadable map
everyone played the game everyone has
you know had been part of it saw
something special in this game all-stars
quickly established itself as dota's
quintessential iteration and in march
2004 the map's development was taken
over by steve ginsu-feek one of dota's
most influential designers
from item recipes to the mighty roshan
himself ginsu was responsible for
ideating and implementing some of dota's
most integral and iconic features and
oversaw the game's development until
february 2005. then ginsu handed over
the reigns to two of his longtime
contributors the first was nikis who
after making a series of significant
contributions eventually became
disenchanted with the project but the
second would go on to become dota's
longest standing designer a mysterious
anonymous visionary whose real identity
remains closely guarded to this day
he is simply known as icefrog
so he will always work around
balancing also connected to
like
everything that makes dota special and
everything that makes the heroes special
um
another something i think he has done
really well and it was under icefrog's
direction that dota blossomed into both
an international sensation
and a bonafide esport when the prizes
started coming i was like oh well we
have like tournaments so obviously some
people is going to come and say well
this is a great game let's play it like
let's put money in it and it started
progressing each year over the course of
the mid to late 2000s dota became one of
the biggest games in the world by 2009
the game's de facto community hub
dotaallstars.com boasted about a million
and a half registered users and received
nearly a million unique visitors each
month
the issue was that technically speaking
dota wasn't a game
it was a mod that couldn't be marketed
sold or commodified since it was
constructed entirely out of
blizzard-owned assets
but its earth-shattering success was too
enticing to ignore
after founding riot games in 2006 mark
tryndamere merrill and brandon rise beck
enlisted the help of two veterans who'd
worked on the original dota to create
and release the game's first spiritual
successor in 2009
league of legends is a
multiplayer competitive session based
action rpg that is sort of considered
the spiritual successor to the popular
warcraft 3 mod defense of the ancients
some very notable dota figures or dota
community figures are have key roles in
uh in the development of league of
legends so steve pendragon has gone and
then on the design side steve ginsweek
and he's the gentleman who's really
leading the design vision
on league of legends and has a very key
role
tensions arose in the community when in
anticipation of league's release
pendragon who'd been tasked with running
dota's de facto website shut it down and
replaced it with a banner promoting
riot's upcoming product it's been
alleged on several occasions that during
this time ice frog had been secretly
working with s2 games whose slightly
more faithful dota spin-off heroes of
new earth was released in 2010. ally
yourself with the legion or the
hillborn to prevail you must preserve
your stronghold
icefrog denied the allegation claiming
that s2 had merely asked him for
permission to create a dota lookalike
and that he viewed the competition as a
good thing i played quite a lot of han
and
i usually say that it's like
it was like dota on
crack or something like that like
everybody's just going around on their
rollerblades being super fast and the
map felt smaller and all the spells were
instant cast about a year after league
of legends release it and han had cut
dota's website traffic by nearly half
with the former having all but dethroned
dota as the world's go-to moba league of
legends
is attempting to be the answer to those
needs that the community is looking for
essentially
you know looking to solve the pain
points of dota and to appeal to a much
wider audience the reason for this was
simple compared to dota which was still
running on warcraft 3's engine league
was more polished streamlined and most
importantly a stand-alone title
it was also easier to play as it either
simplified or removed many of dota's
beautifully complex mechanics it's a big
focus for us in league of legends to
really try to lower the barrier to entry
and to appeal to a much wider audience
the result of this simplification was
twofold on the one hand league achieved
widespread commercial success
on the other it left a sour taste in the
dota community's mouths if they're
trying to imitate what all stars already
did but they don't have the same
creative process behind them so you
can't expect the same result with league
on the rise and han becoming
increasingly popular the fear was that
dota the game that gave birth to the
moba genre
was on the decline that icefrog's genius
would be wasted on an outdated mod
and it was then when all looked to be
lost that the unlikeliest of saviors
stepped in to make every dota player's
dream a reality
[Music]
what does a hero truly mean
that is for you to decide
in october 2009 icefrog published a
forum post announcing that he'd been
hired by renowned game developer valve
to create a true successor to dota
one that would keep intact all of the
game's original heroes items features
and mechanics they contacted icefrog
you know hoping that he would reply
because they were game developers as
well
and he started talking about what he
wanted to do with the sequel and they
said oh we have a great idea why don't
why don't you come here
to valve and we can all build this
together
the only issue was its name
since defense of the ancients was
technically owned by blizzard valve
couldn't use it the term dota on the
other hand was something that blizzard
was willing to look the other way on as
long as it didn't stand for anything but
it was simple weighty and said
everything it needed to
dota 2. one is to you know build the the
sequel that icefrogs wanted to build
for what he was doing with with dota and
then in addition to you know the tens of
millions of people who are already
playing that is also try to figure out
how to make the experience uh more
accessible to new players from the very
outset it was clear that valve had given
icefrog all the resources needed to
create a worthy successor to the
original dota valve wanted dota 2's
debut to be big so before the game had
officially released they decided to
organize a tournament where the world's
best dota teams could simultaneously try
out the new game and vi for the coveted
aegis of champions
they called it the international a
tournament summoning the finest dota
teams from across the globe
the inaugural international was held at
gamescom 2011 and was single-handedly
shout-casted by toby tobiwan dawson it's
the first time we're gonna see teams of
this caliber assembled in one location
everything about it sounded exciting
though not particularly out of the
ordinary
then came the kicker
watch the forums go nuts guys watch the
forums go nuts it is actually confirmed
it is off the freaking hook
1.6 million dollar prize pool
the international wouldn't just be the
biggest tournament in dota but the
biggest tournament in the history of
esports we are now at the final day of
the international dota 2 championships
it is navi we have a one game advantage
sitting very very sweetly in the grand
final who will get a shot at the one
million dollars the onslaught will
continue the mid tower is already being
pushed the tier 4 tower is going to go
down and running in right now is the
rest of nazi they're running forward to
1 million
and they will get it the gg is the call
from ehome navi have just won one
million dollars he home to take home 250
000 in second place but navi
with the issuing of one check valve had
made dota 2 a game that wasn't even out
yet the single most lucrative esport on
the planet
there's moments of esports to the
landmark and this is one of them in
cologne and na'vi the winners you guys
have just made history the beauty of the
international was in the message it sent
it told the world that dota 2 wasn't
just another esport it was the esport
the only moba the only game in which
winning a world championship wouldn't
just allow you to make a living it would
change your life
price money has always been a
huge part of it because
when you can make so much money that it
will change your life for the rest
of your life
uh
it brings a special kind of flair to it
i think
[Music]
a month after the inaugural
international came to a close valve put
dota 2 into open beta and unlike league
of legends valve didn't put playable
characters behind paywalls making dota 2
an entirely free to play experience
despite its difficulty the game quickly
gained popularity favorable reviews and
media attention have you ever heard of
the video game it's called dota 2. i i
not until 5 45 this morning when i got
the email i had not in full disclosure i
had never heard of it as well but i'm
learning it is a huge deal but it would
take nearly two years of testing and a
second international before the game was
given a full retail release a month
before the third international
everything hangs in the balance it all
comes down to this one more game two
million dollars on the table winner
first place at the international the
ages and the prestige of being the best
dota 2 team in the world to this day ti3
remains one of the most important events
in the history of dota he's got bkb but
no boots of travel
as well they aren't going to fight but
now if they go over the throne it could
be game buttocks down alliance are doing
it they need a little more of those to
fall down in jeopardy there's a glimpse
it's going to be their last stand
then he's back he's gonna try to focus
everybody but there's so much stuff
there's no more glyph available down to
about half hp a quarter hp alliance
surrounding him from all sides
in addition to boasting one of the
greatest finals of all time it was the
tournament for which valve unveiled what
is perhaps their single most significant
contribution to esports
the compendium
every time that you guys play a match or
create an item or contribute to the
compendium you're helping make dota
better for the rest of us valve
structured it so that two dollars and
fifty cents from each compendium sale
would be contributed to the tournament's
prize winnings they also set up stretch
goals which when reached would award
owners with additional skins couriers
huds and in-game taunts when you play
with lena you tend to get burned
the compendium raised ti-3s prize pool
to a staggering 2.8 million dollars 1.2
million over ti-1 and 2.
over the next year dota 2 saw a surge in
popularity from competitors
to content creators
this is purge bringing you first person
gameplay commentary i'm gonna be trying
to do a mid-dragonite to cosplayers
coming up we have vera as temporary
assassin night [ __ ] set from dota 2. it
felt as if dodo was once again
solidifying itself as the world's
quintessential moba dota 2 kinda was
born and dora 1 was reborn with ti-1
so it's so it's so much more than just
the world cup it's it's a part of us now
by ti4 the tournament's prize pool had
gone from an already unparalleled 2.8
million dollars to an earth-shattering
10 million dollars
despite the tournament's famously awful
finals it saw five professional gamers
emerge not only as superstars but actual
millionaires
[Applause]
as the game's peak player count
continued to skyrocket reaching a record
high 1.2 million in february of 2015 so
too did the international's importance
as the be-all and end-all of dota every
ti brings something good
it's
such a nice event as in everything is
done very professionally
it's just about dota there's no other
games there's nothing else like
everybody's there for this game the game
that you've been playing for so long
come ti5 the purse had shot up to a
stunning 18 million dollars and soon
after evil geniuses walked away with the
most coveted championship in competitive
gaming it became clear the international
had become the most magical two weeks on
the esports calendar biggest tournament
in esports every year is the biggest
tournament in esports it's made out to
be such a big thing being a ti you know
it's it's not only the world cup it's
like the
festival of dora but it was also the
most destructive um everything
for like the next couple weeks was just
too surreal and then
there's some major changes
we ended up releasing aui and bringing
in our old teammate artisi
to play with us and
um it's just kind of what everyone on
our team thought was best for us going
into this next year every second place
in ti or below that it's it's a loose
like a big loose and uh if you're not a
winner then nobody's looking at you
anymore everybody feels like
they feel like nobody's except the
winners i feel that's that's how i think
the season
comes down to at least ti turned
professional dota into a never-ending
sea of roster shuffles a soap opera in
which kicking and backstabbing were par
for the course a wild west in which
player contracts sponsorships and
friendships meant nothing an esport in
which literally everything revolved
around a single tournament yeah it's a
very beautiful game and it allows you to
express yourselves in so many ways and
i think ti is
is the place to do it because that's
where everybody is also you know trying
to show their best like trying to really
get themselves out there like this is
what i've been playing dota for 10 years
for this is what i can do can you do it
better than me and then that's when the
best team wins
it had become apparent that if dota was
to continue to grow a redistribution of
wealth was an order
it's first place it's go big or go home
but the big teams get big money but the
9th to 16th place are nothing and their
salaries are not worth considering while
in sports you have a salary that you can
live off that changing the lives of five
players while the rest struggled to earn
annual incomes wasn't a sustainable way
to build a competitive infrastructure
something needed to change
following ti5 valve was determined to
bring dota to the next level they
started by releasing reborn the single
largest gameplay update dota had seen in
nearly a decade this is stuff we've been
waiting for for a long ass time
and they just wanted to amalgamate it
into a giant ass patch which they have
done nicknamed dota 3 by the community
dota 7.0 update brought the game into
the source 2 engine redesigned its user
interface introduced the first non-dota
all-stars hero and outfitted each hero
with their own talent tree
next valve unveiled the dota major
championships a series of multi-million
dollar tournaments that would be
scattered throughout the year
culminating in the international itself
okay i've got it they've got the tg out
from secret oh gee they fight all the
way through the lower bracket and will
be clean the champions of the first ever
dota 2 major live here in frankfurt with
the help of reborn the introduction of
majors and the evolution of the battle
pass 2016 became dota 2 single most
successful year to date as ti6 grew near
it felt as if the game's professional
scene had achieved some much needed
stability given that og had won two of
the three majors
oh gee are doing it liquid they can't
withstand the punishment oh gee are the
manila major champions
second time the first ever team to
repeat
and then in typical ti fashion none of
the teams who were supposed to win even
came close og newbie lgd and secret
imploded at various points in the
tournament failed to make top eight and
gutted their rosters immediately after
it ended i ideally had this team
in my head
tf5 was over that i had a team that i
could play with for 10 years and
i still feel like it's the same
i i do not know what the future holds
like even for myself
you never know
instead ti6 found the unlikeliest of
champions
now the last serve they found
we are ripped apart the blind bags it
won't be enough for game of thrones
are your international 2016
champions
despite making one of the greatest ti
runs of all time wings were a largely
unknown roster they turned down
sponsorships and streaming contracts in
an effort to focus on playing
maintenance
wings reminded the world that ti is a
fickle untameable beast
a battle royale in which anyone can
emerge victorious
the international is the big one you can
win as many mages as you want her but if
you take ti you become immortal from a
spectator standpoint ti's
unpredictability is a good thing dota is
its own animal every single game of dota
is different and after every patch it
takes months to figure out what's the
optimal strategy but from a business
standpoint it's a nightmare how is an
owner or sponsor expected to enter an
esport where contracts and consistency
had little to no bearing on a team's
ability to win a world championship
better yet why would they very important
for for teams or organizations such as
ours to
to have this outside framework built
around dota so that we don't lose our
investment from one day to the next or
whenever ti is over or if we fail to
qualify for ti
by march 2017 dota's peak player count
had fallen below a million for the first
time in over a year
and by ti7 its average player count had
decreased by over 100 000. there's
always gonna be enough players it'll
just never be as big as it was and
that's the critical point to where the
shift comes when do you take something
from the community or when it when is
something visibly taken that makes you
look weak and nothing is put in its
place
much of dota 2's initial player base had
been made up of those who grew up on
all-stars and after nearly six years
valve still hadn't found a way to make
the game accessible to new players
i don't have a cc sorry dude
yeah i just got [ __ ] clapped
really one ability
from 2017 onwards it became resoundingly
clear that valve had no interest in
creating a franchise league with the lcs
and overwatch league being framed as the
future of esports people started to
wonder whether dota 2 would have a place
in that future
[Music]
and then in august of 2018 og provided
an incredible impassioned reminder about
what makes dota so unique
[Applause]
they've done it
[Applause]
i've done it here ladies and gentlemen
your grand champions
[Applause]
despite the primordial monolithic status
of all stars and the grand entrance of
its near perfect successor dota never
became the biggest esport in the world
and chances are it never will
but that's okay
because if tia taught us anything it's
that dota isn't about angel investors 37
million baby car sponsorships we just
announced our partnership with honda or
sneaker deals make sure to check out the
website kswiss.com slash immortals it
isn't about popularity wow like why is
that mean or profitability not a viewing
viewers watching your game's dead okay
it's about community dota is a game that
unites everybody
it doesn't matter what country you're
from or race you are it's kind of like a
bond that is shared
normally normally
i can't thank you enough for
opening up yourself and your family
and sharing your story with everyone
it's about challenging yourself
oh what's up [ __ ]
w coming out from the dragon it's about
capturing the hearts and minds of
competitors and turning them into
champions
it's about building an esport that's
fueled by nothing except a pure
unadulterated love for the game
[Music]
it's about making something out of
nothing the game is free to play but it
stays afloat because people love it so
much it's about loving this beautiful
unforgiving
genre defining games so much that it
becomes a part of who you are
and when you think about it isn't that
kind of the point
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button